hello reject nation how you do it Greg
is my name my name is John we are gonna
talk about Leigh Whannell Blum house
tilts newest flick called upgrade before
we do that I wanted to tell you guys a
little cool story that happened with
John and I we gotta meet Leigh Whannell
it was really cool time but then
something especially cool happened Logan
Marshall Green who is a star of this
movie I saw the movie the imitation a
couple months ago loved him in it
quickly became like this actor I was
like who is this guy I love him yeah
he's one of my favorite current working
act and then I remembered some other
movies I've seen him in like why isn't
this guy more famous we went to the
premiere of up and he just retweeted her
tweet we went to the movie premiere and
all night I was really nervous about
going up to this guy so we saw the movie
because I loved him in it made me more
nervous we went to this afterparty
I'm like I should say something to him I
was good to him too you know he's the
star of the night so I mean he's in a
circle of friends and I'm doing that
awkward thing where I'm just standing by
waiting to see if I could like get a
moment to say something to him and the
second he looks at me he breaks away
from the circle he puts his hand on my
shoulder he's like I I know you you're
the real rejects right like yeah he's
like I saw your video because we did
upgrade trailer reaction
he's like I didn't even know what
reactions weren't so I thought I got it
I watched a couple more of your videos
we started talking for a little bit he
was saying he saw me when he was walking
the red car was like where's your buddy
I'm gonna go get him right now God John
yeah he was just incredibly nice it was
a highlight because he is like one of
our favorite actors working right now
yeah that's just a little cool story
everyone share with you guys was like
one of the coolest nerd moments yeah
yeah the consortium of people in that
room and to have that be the Cheerios
yeah actually talked about this movie so
this movie it starts off as a simple
premise it basically takes place in the
near distant future where technology is
like it's better than what we have now
you know upgrades on drone technology
upgrades on automatic vehicle technology
where they could just like Timecop or
they just drive without you having to be
behind the wheel it's that low five sci
fi where there are futuristic things but
there are still cruddy parts of town you
know there's don't run down areas it's
more like the 80 sci-fi film there's the
tone and style of something like
terminator but more along the lines of
I'd say a Robocop kind of movie and in
this world though you got this main
character named gray played by Logan
Marshall green ray is a technophobe he's
more of a dude from our era really more
of a hands-on kind of guy he doesn't
really like all these technological
advancements a lot of the themes of this
movie deal with a humanity and their
relationship with technology so in this
plot something happens where his wife
gets killed he becomes paralyzed but
because he gets paralyzers the person he
encountered earlier who's created this
technology called stem he has like this
owner of a huge computer company who's
got this experiment yeah tech that's
supposed to bridge the gap between his
brain and his severed spinal cord bases
so it allows him to start walking again
but stem also has a personality and a
voice of its own I instead
the system operating your body for you
stem is played by a guy the voice names
Simon maiden he does great voice work in
the film and a lot of the great
chemistry in the film comes down to
logan marshall green and stem beyond him
being able to walk again
it's a highly advanced computer you mean
he might hear comparisons probably said
something like Jarvis stem has the
ability to do though is if grey wants to
surrender to it stem can take over his
body and essentially make him a badass
action hero he sets out on a revenge
mission it's a cool action movie plot
what I think was surprising for
everybody was how much deeper this film
is it doesn't get carried away which
trying to be overly deep but there's a
lot more nuance to the film a lot more
themes and surprises and twists that
people I just don't think we're expected
you get all the cool stuff you want but
you get cool character and you get cool
plot as well yeah it's smartly conceived
and smartly written so even though it is
borrowing a simple setup you know Leigh
Whannell always has a certain amount of
punch with his writing and also now too
I feel like he's come into his own as a
director and all that kind of serves
yeah to make this a lot more interesting
than you know a lot of revenge movies
are there's a humor about it there's
some great action sequences in it let's
just really touch on logan marshall
green's performance yes one of my
favorite things about this dude is he
can do a fully-fledged character with a
whole personality but also he's so good
at capturing trauma not in like a showy
way it's it's not like screaming and
every ten minutes
like his there's this level that he has
where he's trying to block it and that's
more realistic you can see it behind the
eyes and even when he's paralyzed you're
like I really believe he's paralyzed
like his physical body language formants
this one cuz even there are times when
he has to act in spite of his body yeah
like you emote as a person whose body is
doing the things that he's not
controlling and Wow
even that like there's a lot this movie
demands of him and he sells it all
there's great choreography in this film
a lot of people have compared the plot
his style of kind of like a John wick I
heard several people chatter that after
the movie was done it's like a
futuristic side
by John wakin in certain ways or the
taxied oh yeah yeah sure one of the few
questions I asked Logan was a common
Logan by the way Ezra buddies LMG yeah
did he do martial arts training for this
and he said he didn't want to like no
obviously a martial art they obviously
did choreography for the film and he did
a lot of rehearsal for the film but he
didn't actually do training for it he
didn't want to move like a martial
artist he wanted him it's all cocking
back and stuff like yeah whereas this
was all efficiency and a lot of the way
you could even see it in the trailer
it's really interesting to see a dude
who's like doing these fight sequences
and a lot of the times he has to do a
performance where he's not even sure but
his body's doing yeah his body is doing
all of this with ease and he's just
along for the ride and it's fascinating
to watch his face ball this is happening
and there's some gore in here that I
think is utilized so well it's never you
know to the point where they're just
being gory for Gore sake it's always a
punctuation
it's a punctuate it has an effect and I
love how his character doesn't adjust to
the gore so well very human it's a human
reaction to the gore that happens and I
don't want to give away the details of
it because there's several scenes that
do it in such a great way or I'm like
mando riding on this character is so
well done guys say you know this is an
original movie there's no comic-book
property at least for my understand
there's no commented property associated
with this it's not a franchise it was
the premiere but it's not like the
majority of this packed theater was
personally involved with the film a lot
of the people that showed up were people
who just won screaming tickets to go see
it that film garnered quite a bit of
applause and cheers throughout the film
pretty much every major action sequence
got like a good read it wasn't even
scattered it earned its Jif you've seen
the trailer reactions that was the
theater
yeah and rare is the day where the
reaction will match like oh my god yeah
that like we were doing even that big
scene that they show in the trailer it's
still incredibly effective when you
watching the actual theater and you
can't help but cheer when it goes there
ya can't help but cheer
we're gratifying just as a film fan to
go into something that isn't resting on
nostalgia cross over previous properties
anything just purely earning that
applause in those cheers with just sheer
in jab and sheer force of punch you know
it was great and a lot of the main
credit goes to Leigh Whannell for his
writing and direction on the film it was
cool to see him do insidious three and
to cut his teeth but this feels like a
really confident step for him before it
gets like gory or any action sequences
there's a lot of build-up to it which is
the right way to do it it's an actual
right way to do it you know the actual
setup you actually get to know you're
here really care about the character
where any of this crazy mayhem starts
really going down which is nice and
refreshing and what I love about his
writing with this was a little bit later
on in the film you are reminded that
this guy did write saw the first one do
the talk about the first saw do you
think you know the twist you think you
know the surprises but then oh wow I
actually there's stuff I just did not
see coming that works very well for the
film and it's one of those films that
will push you to the edge make you go
what what but then the more you think
about it the more you're like oh I guess
oh yeah I guess so Wow
you know his uniqueness on his camera
angles I thought was great there's a lot
of really cool stylistic camera angles
in here and it's never just for show off
II purposes always used in this line
with something specific to comfort or en
to the visual and especially to
compliment
Logan Marshall green state of mind in
those scenes yeah that was probably the
best part about it was you feel like
you're in his State of Mind and also the
psalmist has really cool designs overall
I like how in the future it's not nic
overblown with crazy sci-fi and the
production design I like that cyberpunk
as you say I like that cyberpunk flare
to it and you see in the trailer or very
brief Schatz relates dudes have like
gods planet in their hands yeah it's
kind of like a video game but it's it
works and it's awesome oh yeah yeah it's
like there's certain things like the
cars are really sleek and you're like
yeah I buy that and then the things like
the body mods are really grungy looking
and yeah can you believe that like it's
probably black market technology
definitely yeah it just goes to creating
this world that feels very lived in even
though this is a pretty compact movie
there's some additional performances in
here there's a Betty Gabriel she plays a
detective who's investigating the murder
of his wife
Benedict Hardy who's the main villain in
the movie gives a really surprising
subtle performance and effectively he's
like the right level of creepy yeah this
could have been whammed up but it was
done really well
well they don't build him up to be
anything more than he is which is good
everything in that movies on the right
level I feel like and there's another
dude named harrison gilbertson who plays
aaron the guy create stem who reminds me
of who's the guy from a cure for
wellness yeah when the film was done I
was with my girlfriend and John and I'm
pretty sure all of us revenue was never
like that's one of my favorite films of
the year usually just easily one of my
favorite immediately liked it yeah made
it is it was making impressions like
partway through the movie experience and
it was done we were just like yes yeah
you know and I like the ending because
the ending can be challenging for an
audience beyond the side that might love
it you'll be on the side that might know
about that ending personally I thought
it was great I think that ending butted
like that's a that's like a Leigh
Whannell maneuver right there yeah I
feel like maybe people might have issues
with the twist but I think the ending is
pretty terrific definitely definitely I
highly recommend this movie guys go
watch it please do yourself a favor
enough go watch it all right well you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell to get
notified every time one of our vids is
up also check us out on patreon
full-length TV show reactions weekly Q&A
'z music video coverage would love to
have you become a patron oject
today